the house Democrats are all completely
bananas in now a famous incident
Congressman Jamal Bowman of New York
called the fire alarm uh he thought he
was opening the door and now this
morning we've actually got video Fox
News I think it could be exclusive video
of him turning himself in uh he's going
to plead guilty to a single false fire
alarm charge he's agreed to pay a
maximum fine of a th000 bucks here he is
just a little while ago talking about
the jam he's
in as I said from the beginning I was
not trying to disrupt any you know
official government proceeding so I'm
glad you know the uh investig ation
found that that was the case uh the
misdemeanor charge of pulling the alarm
I admitted that from the very beginning
so you know got to got to take
responsibility for it um you know we
have a deal in place so looking forward
to uh paying the fine and 3 months later
it being dismissed and uh hopefully
continuing to do work in my district I
mean the video is pretty clear that he
tore the signs down and pulled the alarm
and walked past multiple Law Enforcement
Officers without saying hey I made a a
mistake I accidentally pulled the
alarm